great pleasure to introduce Michael who
will be who graciously volunteered to
give an entire day of lectures on
streaming and sketching algorithms
um I'm very grateful to you for
presenting for the day this sequence of
lectures today seem like a Natural
Bridge from everything we've talked
about in the last two days about a bit
more Robin grappling your algebra and
graph data structures so what we'll be
doing in the next two days talking a bit
more about optimization and linear
algebraic data structures and talking
about streaming and sketching as a
natural bridge between all of these
things and thank you so much for
volunteering to present for the whole
day
um so Michael uh capralov is a professor
at epfl who's done a wide range of works
on sublinear time algorithms a number of
influential works on streaming and
sketching on graph processing on
sublinear graph algorithm design and I
think his work really again like so many
of the speakers fits well into the
programs from the mix of work he's done
on streaming and sketching and sublinear
techniques and how exactly they've
interacted things with spectral craft
Theory and algorithm and design so I
think from all of his work just by
itself he's well suited to give the
lectures today on a personal note I am
particularly excited for uh Michael's
lectures and grateful that he agreed
because when I was a grad student one of
the main ways I learned about this area
was by working with and arguing with you
and listening to your many words of
wisdom when I was a grad student so I'm
excited this will be recorded and then
in the future I can just point my grad
students towards your lecture and have
some of the experience I'm also excited
to maybe find out I learned some things
wrong a number of years ago and they can
have it corrected anyway thank you very
much I look forward to your talk all
right uh thanks a lot for the
introduction and thanks a lot for
volunteering me for
the marathon lectures on sketching all
right so today I will talk about
sketching
um
I will start by talking about some of
the classical sketching techniques that
were designed basically in the 90s and
early 2000s for with applications and
data streaming in mind then in the
second part of this we'll move to 2010s
and see how to apply these originally
data streaming techniques to solve
linear algebra problems
um and uh later we will talk about graph
sketch all right great so uh let's start
uh sketching for data streams so we will
be talking about the streaming model of
computation a lot so let me introduce it
uh introduce it uh to you
this streaming model of computation was
introduced in a very influential paper
of along Matthias and zagre in 96 this
was a paper on approximating frequency
moments of data streams
more on that later
in the streaming model of computation
one thinks of the algorithm as observing
a very long stream of data items and at
this point these data items could really
be anything could be IP packets tweets
search queries what not now as the
algorithm is scanning this very long
stream of data items it must maintain a
small amount of state so use a small
amount of memory at every point in the
Stream and at the end of the stream or
rather really at any point in the Stream
we should be able to stop the algorithm
and ask it to approximate some basic
statistics of the stream for us
okay so what are those basic statistics
and we'll get to this in a second with a
little bit uh more formally let's define
the model we will think of single pass
streaming algorithms that's the smallest
number of passes that you can take over
the stream
um the algorithm will take a single pass
over the data items we call them i1 I2
through I capital N we'll assume for
Simplicity that capital N is known
in some settings you can guess it in
some settings you can use an upper bound
because we'll have weak dependence on
the length of the stream these data
items for the purposes of this now talk
will really be numbers from some
Universe one through Little M okay now
as the algorithm is scanning the stream
it will maintain a sublinear amount of
storage so typically
um it will be a low polynomial in the
length of the stream or really just poly
logarithmic
in the size of the Stream
uh we will measure storage in bits and
sometimes for convenience and words
where a word is log n Bits for some
appropriate definition of n
we want our streaming algorithms to be
fast so when a new data item arrives
they should be able to update their
state quickly and most of the algorithms
that we will talk about will be
randomized this is for good reason uh
most interesting streaming problems do
not admit low space deterministic
Solutions so this is really necessary
all right so what are those streaming
problems that we are interested in
solving
um as I said this is about approximating
basic statistics of data streams so
today I will talk a lot about the Heavy
Hitters problem
um
so let's formally Define it so here we
take a single Passover the data items I
want for in and besides the stream which
is given to us as input we're also given
a parameter K and our task is to be able
to Output the K most frequent items that
appear in the Stream okay these are
known as Heavy Hitters
but
we want to maintain a small amount of
space as we scan the stream and we will
shoot for an algorithm with order K log
n storage
some restrictions apply we'll discuss
what sort of approximation we get etc
etc but this is in general way better
than storing all the items Okay small
this is logarithmic and the length of
the string
okay so here's an example a stream so
our items let's say are from a universe
of size M where m is 10 so the items are
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten and let's say the first item on
the stream that arrives is three then
item four six three etc etc so you see
as the stream is coming in I'm also
updating a frequency histogram uh for
the stream so so far
element 3 arrived three times element
two arrived once four arrived ones etc
etc
good so this goes on and on uh wonderful
and at the end of the Stream
we realized let's say element three
arrived um six times which is the
maximum so if K is one then we're
looking for the top most frequent
element we should be outputting three
hopefully
good so this is a this is the formal
definition of the problem a few words
about the motivation well first let's
start with the motivation comes from the
90s that's from analyzing traffic uh
internet traffic going through routers
so here's a router pictured on the slide
so a router is an object through which
IP packets flow and every IP packet for
our purposes has a source IP address and
the destination IP address so you can
really think of the distribution of
packets flowing through the router as
being described by a matrix so here's
this Matrix the rows are indexed by The
Source destination The Source IP
addresses the columns by the destination
AP addresses so that's a huge Matrix
oh before we turn on the router The
Matrix is all zeros nothing has flown uh
through the router and then the packets
start going through it as packets go
through it uh one can think of updating
this Matrix just record how many packets
were going from a given source to a
given destination okay so this goes on
and on
um
yeah so we're looking at big data
streams so they're very long okay the
stream is done
um excellent so you know at the end of
the stream of course most of the entries
in The Matrix are zero but still a lot
of packets typically flow through
routers so the number of non-zeros is
very large and way too large for the
router to store this uh these uh the
identities of the source destination
pairs but now uh the question a question
that a router might want to resolve is
what are the dominant flows which source
destination IP addresses exchanged a lot
of packets
uh and this is exactly the Heavy Hitters
problem so in this particular case the
top two are for these four and five
good
um why would we care about dominant
flows for example to
um and to understand if there is a
denial of service attack going on
because in this case uh usually a lot of
traffic goes through a small number of
source destination pairs
good
so how can one imagine solving this
problem again the trivial thing to do
would be to just store all the non-zero
entries in The Matrix that's too much
and today we'll design the account
sketch algorithm of Moses Chen and uh
for our Colton that will give us an
exponential Improvement
good
um
a little bit more about the motivations
with more of a 2000s motivation
um
estimating search statistics and data
streams so imagine that we are given a
set of items as a stream say queries on
google.com over a period of time so hey
for example here's a stream of my
queries on Google some time ago looking
for flights from Geneva to New York then
going for a coffee and looking for
flights again and the most frequent
items in this set would be genua to New
York because it appears twice
okay
good so again a trivial solution is to
store everything but that's
prohibitively expensive in the context
of queries on google.com over a period
of time but wants them do much better
and we'll shortly see how
uh good so on must uh add here that uh
we will look at the asymptotic
complexities asymptotic space complexity
of these algorithms but of course a very
natural question to ask is whether the
constants are small and whether one can
truly use these techniques in practice
uh the answer here is yes so for example
a different algorithm but one can do
cardinality estimation and data streams
with very good constants and similarly
count sketch that we will discuss today
is also used at Google for example for
finding most frequent items in this
databases
good
um so this is the motivation now let's
design the algorithm
okay
um
again so
we're getting a data stream and we want
to Output the K most frequent items
using order K login bets or actually
words of storage that's what we're going
to do
fantastic now formally this is asking to
design a primitive that one could fire
could could call find top
the task is to find the top K elements
most frequent ones in the Stream this
primitive takes the stream implicitly as
inputs and K the number of elements to
find wonderful now however it's more
more useful to think about a different
primitive which we call Point query okay
Point query is the following it's given
a stream as input and besides the stream
it's also given a num data item I and it
is asked to return the number of times
the item I appeared so far in the Stream
okay
Point query is an extremely powerful
primitive it really knows a lot and if
we have this point query primitive then
of course we can also find the top K
elements in a data stream
that's pretty simple wait start by
storing the first K elements and then
whenever a new element that we're not
holding in our memory comes in we just
ask the super powerful Point query how
many times that element appears in the
Stream so far and if needed we kick out
one of the elements we store and we put
this one in excellent so the reduction
is very simple but that's because Point
query is very powerful
all right so in general for Simplicity
we will assume that our items are
ordered according to frequency so
frequency of item one is the largest F2
is next etc etc
um
at this point we're interested in
designing this point query primitive
that given I
outputs f i exactly and somehow we're
supposed to do this in order K login
space or some parameter okay now that of
course is completely impossible okay uh
this is way too powerful this is asking
to exactly predict the count using a
small amount of space
um imagine a stream where all items
appear a small number of times one or
two or zero that's information Theory
good so that's clearly impossible so we
need to allow a little bit of
approximation so let's throw in some
approximation instead of finding the top
K elements exactly we will find them
approximately so we'll call this find
approximate top now it has
three parameters the stream K and
Epsilon the Precision parameter
we're now asking to return a set of K
items whose frequencies are not much
smaller than the frequency of the case
most frequent type
specifically what I'm reporting I should
have a frequency at least one minus
Epsilon times f k
fantastic that seems a little bit easier
good
to achieve this goal uh it would be
enough to design an approximate Point
query primitive that
given the stream and an item I returns
an approximation F hand of I and this
approximation needs to be Epsilon FK
close to the true frequency all right so
that's what we will what we will try to
design
except it's actually also not possible
um
imagine again a stream in which all
elements appear let's say zero uh one or
two times all right this is if you look
at the frequency histogram it's very
flat so then this of course I allowed
some approximation but it's not really
doing anything for me as long as Epsilon
is smaller than a constant this is as
good as exact estimation all right so in
reality we will design an approximate
Point query uh primitive except under
the additional constraint that the
stream is such that these top K elements
that we're looking for
contribute a non-trivial fraction of the
stream in terms of their frequencies
under some measure and we'll get to the
measure sure okay
um
any questions presumably not
all right excellent so uh so that's
that's our goal now indeed we will be
observing a stream of data items items
come from a universal size Little M and
then we'll design a approximate Point
query primitive that will approximate F
hat I the frequency of I
pretty well and we will specify the
space complexity and all that later
we'll just design a nice primitive and
then we'll see which uh properties it
satisfies
good
so as I said before we will only be able
to design a good primitive under the
additional assumption that somehow the
top K elements in the Stream contribute
a non-trivial fraction of the stream so
it's good to introduce some notation for
these top K elements we'll call them the
head of the stream so here's a stream
coming in here's its frequency histogram
and as promised it is ordered in
[Music]
um
non-increasing order so F1 is the
highest
um suppose that our K is four and we're
looking for the top four elements these
most frequent items we'll call the head
and we'll color them green throughout
this like sure and the rest will call
the tail
fantastic
to start designing such an estimate I
would like to ask a very basic question
which is suppose that I'm only given a
budget of one word or one counter
to summarize the Stream
how should I use this budget one counter
to approximate the frequencies of data
items
we'll Design This basic estimate that
uses a single counter
and it will turn out that it's the very
nicest
so what can you do with one counter
okay
if you think of the items as strange you
could look at one data
I would just say okay I would say the
most trivial thing to do if I have one
counter to me is just every time an item
comes in I incremented my counter by one
so I'll just compute the length of the
stream and at the end of the day my if
you ask me what the frequency of item I
is I'll just look up the counter and
I'll say it's this
all right uh but it will do something
that is so somewhat similar but actually
critically different right so uh instead
of just counting the length of the
stream what we're going to do is choose
a hash function that Maps the elements
of the universe uniformly at random to
plus minus one
okay and our counter will start out as
zero at the beginning of the stream and
then when an item comes in we'll simply
increment the counter not by one but by
the but by the sign of the item
okay
um
good so this is our streaming algorithm
fantastic
hello I need to give you the estimation
primitive uh at the end of the stream
you give me some I and asked me to
approximate the frequency count what do
I do well I I can't just take the
counter and give it to you because it
could be negative for instance maybe the
stream contains my item all the way and
it had minus one fine what I do is I
take the counter and multiply it by the
sign of my item
so that's the type of estimator that
will at least be good if the stream
contains just my item and nothing else
okay
good I would like to convince ourselves
off is that this estimator is
pretty good that is close to f i the
true answer with some reasonable
probability at least for some
interesting streams so let's let's
understand
so how we're going to do this well first
of all establish that this estimator is
unbiased it's a randomized estimator so
first of all we can compute the
expectation convince ourselves that the
expectation is correct
will show that the variance is small
hopefully
analyze the variants
good so uh what's the expectation of
this estimate so it's my counter times s
i what is this the counter is just the
sum over all positions in the Stream of
the sign of the item IP that comes in
the piece of position times s of I
excellent now that can be equivalently
written as the sum over all elements J
in my universe number of times J
occurred which is FJ times the sine of J
so that's how I was incrementing my
counter when that item K1 times s i
so there's one special term in the sum
which is when J equals I so let me
separate that out so I get f i times the
sine of I squared plus the contribution
of the other element other than I
uh fantastic sine of I squared is always
one great
um and
now it's clear that this very simple
estimator is actually quite non-trivial
um because
it is f i we can think of this as f i
the true answer plus some contribution
from the rest of the stream but let's
look at this contribution a little bit
more closely imagine for a second that
the stream is like this the item I that
I am that I'm being that I'm querying
maybe is the heavy hitter the most
frequent item on the stream right and
imagine also that the other items in the
Stream all occur bounded number of times
so the frequency histogram is sort of
benign in the sense that I have one item
sticking out and then the rest are
pretty flat
now so think of these fjs as a small
const now the science as J are random
so the sum here will actually have a lot
of cancellations
right and so this is what makes uh this
estimator with random sign distinctly
better than the absolutely trivial one
learner okay I have one counter I just
sum up the length of this tree okay and
that'll be basically where the power of
count sketch is coming from
good
okay so now let's analyze the
expectation formally right I will just
put expectations on on top of uh of this
on top of this
now the signs are purely random or
really pairwise Independence is enough
here so the expectation here is zero and
indeed the estimator is unbiased
so now uh what is the variance I want to
convince myself that the estimator is
actually close to fi or with high
probability whatever it is
right
um
good so what is the variance uh well the
variance of a random variable is the
expected squared deviation from its mean
amazing uh we know that the mean of our
estimator is fi so really we're
interested in the expectation of the
squared contribution from the other
elements J that are other that are not I
okay
so let me just open up the square what
do we get we get a sum over J and J
Prime both different from I uh product
of frequencies f j f j Prime Times sine
of J times sine of J Prime
and s i a squared this is one so nice
um
good so now if we look at this
we realize that
if J if we consider the terms
corresponding to G distinct from J Prime
then again these signs as J times as J
Prime are zero in expectation
again even if this if the sign even is a
um
or just pairwise independent excellent
so the variance is really governed by
the diagonal terms and so the variance
of the estimator is nothing but the
summation of the squared frequencies
over everything but I
uh-huh good so that's what we proved for
the variance uh the variance is the L2
Norm squared of the rest of the universe
and so by chebyshev's inequality with
high constant probability our estimator
is
about the L2 Norm of the rest of the
stream close to the True Value
okay good so the question is this seems
nice it's nice for these streams that
contain a single element and then the
rest is pretty flat as I mentioned
before but is it good for everything
else
not clear so let's uh let's think about
this so again here's a picture
illustrating my previous point if the
item to be estimated as the heavy hitter
and everybody everything else is pretty
flat then we are in a fantastic shape
but of course if we are estimating an
item that actually is slow is actually
low then the estimator is corrupted by
the heavy hitter so that's not good and
we need to fix it
how do we fix it we'll fix it by hashing
uh what we're going to do is partition
the universe into random subsets
of appropriately The Chosen size and
we'll run the best basic estimator on
these hashers sub-sampled streams this
will make sure that we will estimate
will never be under that position
good so this brings us to the uh count
sketch algorithm of cherry cartoon and
pharah Colton
um
the main ingredients are
to run the basic estimate on a sub-samp
holder hashed stream so this will reduce
the variance of the estimator and then I
will do some aggregation using medians
or repeat this experiment a bunch of
times to make sure that the error
probabilities are low
so here's a pictorial representation uh
here's our stream there's the head of
the stream and the tail of the stream in
red
um note that this is the universe not
the stream itself and we're hashing it
into some number of buckets
um for example if we hashed our universe
of size 10 into 8 buckets then we get
eight sub-sampled streams each bucket
corresponds to a substream uh for
example the subsample stream of item one
is all occurrences of one and six
Collision in this orange bucket
similarly the subsampled stream of item
five is all occurrences of five and
seven because of this condition
right
just to repeat again we're hashing the
universe not the positions in the string
substream of one is all occurrences of
one and six so that's one six one one
and similarly for five and six
great
um
so let's summarize this is our final
count sketch algorithm we will choose
some parameter t
um
and select T random hash functions H1 H2
through HT all of these hash functions
hash items from our universe M to
capital B buckets we'll decide how Big B
is but you should really think of b as
roughly K recall K as the number of
elements where is the number of Heavy
Hitters that we're trying to find
okay uh and we'll also select of course
a t random hash functions S1 S2 through
SD so basically we're just doing uh t
independent repetitions of our basic
estimate in
in the hashbox
so the data structure that the
algorithm will maintain is simply an
array so here's this array on the slide
it has t rows and capital B columns the
buckets
the T rows correspond to Independent
repetitions and the columns correspond
to the subsample or hashed streams
here's the actual algorithm uh well upon
receiving an item let's say item five
arriving in the Stream what the
algorithm does is simply goes through
all the T rows in the array for every
row R from one to T it checks where it
applies the hash function the art hash
function to the item arriving looks at
HR of I checks where the item goes we'll
say five goes to this bucket and the
first row and increments the
corresponding
value by the arth sign of the arriving
item okay
I need just run the basic estimates on
the substrings
now
once at the end of the stream we're
asked to approximate the frequency count
for some item I what we do is simply
take the median of all the T estimates
over the rows
any questions about the
mechanics
good
um
uh good good good so
let's state
the actual Precision guarantees of this
outcome so we'll prove the following one
if the number of buckets B is
sufficiently large and sufficiently
large here is B is at least a constant
times K and at least something that
depends on the ratio of the L2 squared
Norm of the tail and the head so to
speak
almost we'll get to this in a second and
if the number of independent
interpretations is chosen to be order
login then we get
good estimates where good is additive
error at most Epsilon times the kth
largest frequency FK simultaneously for
all uh all elements of the universe at
every point in the Stream with high
protein
good
so we'll prove dilemma but before
proving dilemma so let's note that the
space complex complexity of this is
order B log M uh right because log n
repetitions and B buckets in every
repetition uh at the same time I
advertised an algorithm with a space
complexity order K log n so we need to
convince ourselves that b is order k at
least in these natural cases that my
asterisk there
mentioned good so how large is V
essentially it's a question of let's
understand the second term in the max
all right
at this point we exactly come to this
formalization of the claim that I made
at the beginning of this talk that we
will get an algorithm with space
complexity order K log n if the top K
elements in the Stream dominate The
Stream under some measure or at least
provide a non-trivial fraction of the
Stream
good so here's again a pictorial
presentation of the frequency diagram
and let's imagine that the L2 squared
Norm of the tail of the Stream
is comparable to the L2 squared Norm of
the head
or even more specifically here since we
insist on the our error being Epsilon
times F K let's take the total Ultra
squared Norm of the tail and partition
it equally between the
um the top K elements
if
if this equal partitioning of the total
L2 squared Norm does not swamp
the case largest element then we get
exactly the right Precision guarantee so
essentially
as advertised if the top K elements
provide a non-trivial fraction of the L2
Norm then we get the result
there's one other nice uh for
formulation of this note that in general
use B to be at least K the number of
buckets we choose to be at least k then
the errors on the counts uh that we get
are at most square root of 1 over B
times the L2 squared Norm of the two uh
well we'll see this a little bit more
formally in a bit
good all right so now another note on
the space complexity of the algorithm
getting back to my
model example where the stream contains
a single heavy hitter and then all the
other elements arrive with roughly a
constant
constant frequency each
suppose that k equals one so we're just
looking for the heavy hitter industry
and suppose that this element one the
heaviest one appears square root n times
in the Stream and all the other elements
in the Stream are distinct
let's figure out what the space
complexity of finding this element is
using count sketch
so F1 is square root n
and if I is 1 for all the rest of the
I's of which there are at most
now the total L2 squared Norm of the
tail is therefore at most n
whereas F1 squared is n as well
so this ratio in the in the second
argument of the max is actually just one
over Epsilon squared
unless I claim is very surprising
because this heavy hitter appears in a
vanishingly small fraction of the stream
there's a polynomially small fraction of
the stream just squares and positions
out of n so there's absolutely no way
you can find it for example by just
sampling the Stream
uh nevertheless using count sketch we're
able to find such an element by using
only a constant dish amount of space or
up to some blocks
all right uh fantastic so there are
these are just some instantiations of
the bound let's just formally prove the
Lemma and dilemma is again if B is at
least K times the uh K is at least the
max of K and the ratio of L2 Norms tail
to head uh
so to speak then we get good estimates
all right so what governs the
quality of our estimates oh it's
basically just the variance of our basic
estimators that we run on the subsample
stream uh let's fix some element I and
let's fix a row r all right uh let's
understand the Precision of the
estimator
for I given by the arthro
well by the basic estimate analysis that
we did before the variance of this
estimator is the L2 squared Norm
of the
corresponding substring so the sum of
squared frequencies if I sum over those
J's that hash to the same bucket as I
and I also ignore I
and we'll show that
with high constant probability this
variance is just a one over B fraction
of the total L2 squared Norm of the tail
this is natural because we're hashing
into B buckets so something has to go
down with actually there is one nice
point to make here is that this is not
the total Ultra squared Norm is the L2
squared Norm of the tail
that'll have nice implications
good so just to establish this bound
what we do is we look at the variance as
a sum of two terms the first
contribution comes from the head of the
signal the green the dominant elements K
of them
uh and again we only look at those who
those are hash together with I in the
same bucket uh in in the arth hashing
and the second term is the same for the
tail
all right so for each row and each item
we Define three events first event is
the event that our item I does not
collide with any of the headones
recall that are K elements in the head
of the signal and we're hashing into B
buckets and B is at least K with a large
constant so that will most that'll
happen with good constant probability
there is a small variance event and
that's the event that the
variance corresponding to I's bucket
is about a one over B fraction of the
total tail that Will Follow by Markov
and some small deviation event just
meaning that the basic estimator
analysis works
we'll show that all of these three
events hold simultaneously with
probability strictly bigger than two but
no that'll be difficult uh strictly uh
strictly bigger than a half right
our restaurants are not that strong and
then it'll follow that because we take
medians everything
so just it should be pretty clear that
this this is fine but let's go through
the details
um so the no collisions event was what
it's the event that for a fixed element
I and a fixed row R uh the none of the
head elements
other than I called hash into the same
bucket
uh well the probability of collision for
any given J is 1 over B
and B is at least 8K by our setting of
parameters so this happens with
probability at least 7 8.
good uh
the second thing that we needed to hold
was that the uh the variance coming from
the tail element is at most one over B
fraction or so of the total tail well
that's just by linearity of expectation
and the market bound an expectation the
variance is 1 over B of the total tail
and by a marker bound it's at least one
roughly that much good so to summarize
uh conditioned on these events that hold
with high constant probability the
following happens
the first term in the variance coming
from the head is just zero there are no
collisions with the head element
and the second term is small roughly one
over B of the L2 squared mass of the
tail
and now All That Remains is to apply the
small deviation event which was
basically that the basic estimator works
uh putting all this together and doing
some basic algebra we get that good
things happen with probability at least
five over Eights and five over Eights is
at least a half actually bigger than
half fantastic so then uh
what we showed is that for any given I
item in the universe and for any given
row with probability at least five out
of five five over eight
um the estimate that we get is
um
is uh is good
since we get since we have other login
rows and we do independent repetitions
and take medians this happens with
extremely high probability for all items
into all positions in the Stream
this concludes the analysis
any questions about the analysis
okay
okay good good so uh let me make some
remarks I will state some related
results yes
I know the universe yes
uh great Point uh so
uh the point was that to use what we
designed was a point query which given
an item returns a good estimate for a
distributes account and the question is
how do you use this do you just go over
all possible Source destination ID
packets right that will take time uh so
in the context of a streaming
application uh you only use it for the
items that appear in the Stream right so
if I'm actually just scanning the Stream
and
do it comes along all right yeah
items are coming along and then I can
just do this every time and I swap it up
right if I find an item that my query
says is more frequently than something
else
yes so
that works as long as it's only
incremental yeah
it doesn't work but there is a solution
to a generic problem of having such a
filter and finding the good guys it's
something that helpers together with
Casper thank you
several people here and it it solves
that problem how can you deal with
finding the good life
oh sorry yeah
yeah of course yes basically there's the
other questions just to repeat make
those answers here
um the first answer to Bob's question is
indeed that I'm just query the item that
comes in but it is also possible to set
up the sketch a bit differently so that
you can recover the top key elements
from the sketch itself without going
through the entire
I know there's a whole industry and many
amazing results
a very cool one by and uh
yeah so what do you assume about the
hash functions good the question was
what do I assume about the hash
functions the purposes of this analysis
we only need the hash functions to be
pairwise independent right look at the
what did we use we only had pairs of
signs as long as independent everything
is fine yes both for H and for the
science uh in the next lecture we'll
talk about applications to
to linear algebra we will need a bit
more Independence there and also more on
that
other questions
yes can you actually detect that most of
the masses in the head of the stream
okay good question was is it actually
possible to
the most of the mass is in the head of
the Stream
but I mean
but what if it's like what was the hat
is bigger than you think
once the head is bigger and then you'll
notice right then count sketch actually
tells you that
right
well you're on count sketch and this
account sketch will tell you estimates
for the head that are correct sort of
opportunity
so when the head is bigger than the tail
you know that it is
sorry uh so I think your question was is
it possible to detect whether the head
of the signal is bigger than the tail
but
to make it concrete for example if the
L2 squared Norm of the top K elements is
comparable uh
it's Omega
the ultra squared Norm of the rest was
that a question
yes good and so the the answer is I
think this answers your question right
uh that you just run count sketch and
cam sketch gives you estimates for the
Top Gear elements let me just look at
the L2 Norm of these estimates
if it's bigger it only satisfies your
condition then then you're good yes but
I mean if it's very small then you'll
not know normally but like if
like if the stream does not comply it
might might actually end up I don't see
why the attraction
was good
okay so it could be that the head is
actually small
right yes but that's sort of okay okay
let's take it offline because I do want
to end this with a puzzle that's
important okay only absolutions
sure
um all right so uh remarks early uh the
questions and deposits
um so first coming back to Middle's
point about deletions uh right and
actually coming back to the title of
this lecture series and what is
sketching okay so uh one uh one very
important point to make is that
the stream the algorithm will work even
if the items not don't just arrive but
also depart in the Stream so here's
another stream wonderful and an O
element three comes in with a minus
signs and uh the the frequency reduces
right excellent so the point is that if
that happens the algorithm works just
just like it did before it's just that
we don't add the sign we subtract the
sign so the algorithm is linear in the
input that's fantastic and that is
exactly the idea of sketching or linear
sketching uh good
uh good so this is the idea of sketching
and this is what I will talk about for
the rest of uh today it's the idea of
Designing algorithms that are linear in
the input our algorithms take randomized
linear measurements of the input here's
our sketching Matrix uh we'll
instantiate this Matrix at the beginning
of the next lecture to stare at it a
little bit the space complexity is the
number of rows in this Matrix and this x
is really the frequency Vector of the
stream in our heavy headers application
so
because the algorithm is linear it's
very easy to maintain such sketches in
the dynamic streaming setting if items
depart as well as arrive we don't care
just change the plus two minus excellent
um
a couple of more observations before the
puzzle uh comes
um
in the counts cage analysis we made sure
to distinguish between the
head and the tail of the signal in
particular our bounds on the Precision
of the estimates are in depend on the L2
Norm of the tail
this means that for example if the Heavy
Hitters become very very large that does
not affect the the Precision of our
estimator it doesn't get worse
good so suppose that s is a count sketch
Matrix with other K log n rows
um I claim that we actually proved the
following but for every X and RN so not
necessarily
a frequency Vector the entries don't
have to be integers that don't have to
be positive
um if we if x hat is the estimated
Vector as per our estimator right that
just takes medians uh coordinate wise
then the
l l Infinity distance between x and x
hat is bounded by one over root K
fraction of the L2 Norm of the tail of x
so this is known uh this is all with
high probability so this is known as the
L Infinity L2 sparse recovery guarantee
Cloud sketch provides sparse recovery
guarantees
important thing to note is that if x
itself had at most k non-zeros then the
right hand side is actually plane zero
in particular we showed that
the vectors
with at most K non-zeros can be
recovered from order K log and linear
measurement
so I
uh
um
I would like to point out that a our
analysis in fact works for any Vector X
didn't use negativity integriness or
anything and I would like to point out
that the Precision of our estimates
depends on the tail
so if the tail is zero then our recovery
is exact
ly so if the original X had at most K
non-zeros tail is zero so we recovered
the statement that K sparse vectors can
be
reconstructed from other K log n
measurements the number of measurements
can actually be made out of case or this
application is off by a log but it's
still
um
good
yes so now again this L Infinity L2
bound is known as the element L2 sparse
recovery guarantee
um the number of measurements the the
the K log and rows is actually optimal
so if we're not thinking about exact
exactly case parse vectors where the
tail is zero
um but lectures that are close to case
bars where the tail gets to be non-zero
then that's asymptotically optimal
that's a very nice proof of this for
example in uh given by kanduba pure
integer Eric price and David Woodruff in
2010 this basically follows from uh
information theoretic statements about
the capacity of the gaussian channel or
the Shannon Hartley fear actually
imagine that the noise you can make the
noise independent gaussian I need to
make the tail be independent gaussians
and then every linear measurement that
you take is basically some signal which
is
what you're trying to recover plus
gaussian noise and that's why you can
bound the amount of information that any
measurement gives you using statements
about the capacity of the gaussian
channel
the related guarantee is the l202 sparse
recovery guarantee and that just says
that for that for Vector yes
observation is there a smooth
interpolation between the case from the
tail is zero and when it's not and like
characterizing
the upper lower bounds in terms of the
locker is there anything that is like
parameterized by that and can kind of
optimal in there
good so the question was uh basically is
there a smooth lower bound because as I
said if the vector if the table is zero
then you don't need to log in that's
what I'm saying I'm going to say with
small zero you do
um I think you can I don't know where
it's if it's written but but I think you
can extract it right
I think so
but I think you can extract them from
things
yeah yeah okay good so then a related uh
found is the l202 sparse recovery
guarantee that basically says uh that
from other K log and measurements you
can recover an approximation X hat to X
which is on the who's called who's
precision and euclidean Norm is on the
order of the euclidean one at the tail
imagine basically taking this um Fields
again and look checking what it implies
uh for K element some of those range so
there's no pain observation too
uh there's no key and there is a k oh
good mickel's point was uh is there a K
in observation two there is a k because
the right hand side has a tail and tail
implicitly depends on K tail is
everything but the top key great point
um good
yeah and of course you can also make
this one perceptional
so the l2l2 sparse recovery guarantee in
terms of the tail can also equivalently
be restated like this we can recover a
vector an approximation X hat to X which
is just almost as good as the best case
sparse approximation yes
the L2 Norm of the tail is actually the
L2 quality of the best possible case
parse approximation
that's another way of thinking
you said all this is linear right so
does does the tail depend on the
absolute values or just the actual
actors is it like the top K it absolute
value or the top okay good the question
was what is the tail again the tail is
the result of taking X and zeroing out
the K largest coefficients
the
absolute value no there's just zero them
then you get some signal you can measure
whichever Norm you like
all right
um
yes
may I take
five more minutes
uh all right good I do want something
all day I'm not gonna all right all
right there's some benefits okay
uh so so here comes the puzzle
um all right it's a it's a nice puzzle
to
it's a nice puzzle
Helen sketch from matrices all right so
so far we designed the scound sketch
algorithm that takes the vector X
applies some linear measurements to it
compresses it and from this compressed
representation we can recover the top
view coefficients up to some error
excellent now suppose that I want to uh
do the same but for matrices
here's the question there are parties
and you know think of them as a
distributed system they they sit in
different rooms
every one of the parties has a vector X1
X2 through XR these are length n
dimensional vectors
uh there's a coordinator who sits in a
separate room and every party looks at
their Vector uses shared Randomness to
compress the vector down to order B log
n Bits
looks like
all right words so that that's the type
of word so College case should should
fit the belt with words
okay now once the coordinator return
receives these compressed
representations of the vectors uh the
coordinator wants to find the largest
entries in this Matrix a what is the
Matrix a it's the sum of outer products
of the X I's
okay x i x i transpose
and I want no I want the same guarantees
or even slightly weaker so I want to
stated here just slightly weaker I want
to Output an approximation a hat to a
that is pointwise
this good what is this good
the frobenius norm of a matrix is the
euclidean norm
of this Matrix if you think about of it
as a vector so that's really the count
sketch guarantee right except I didn't
write a tail here just for Simplicity I
could also ask for the tail
okay great
uh-huh so how can you do this what could
these uh what could these parties send
so here's a picture
so the the our parties they send
something about their lecture to the
coordinator and I only want a small
number of bits to be
extreme order B log n word
let's assume that the vectors are
integer valued with Napoleon don't worry
about this complexity
what can they say
uh no these are numbers
so absolute value
thank you maker so
any teacher very good okay so every
party as as Miku suggests thank you
simply does count sketch of x i x i
transpose it just looks at XR and
account sketches it uh into B buckets
fantastic but this is slow
I don't like that this is slow every
party has an extra X as input why should
they form x x i x i transpose
it's annoying so good so to flesh out
make a proposal right well we just do
count sketch so now our hash function
Maps the universe n times n
the the entries in The Matrix
um The Matrix slots to be buckets and
the sine function is from n times M to
minus 1 1. fantastic and then we can for
every B form the right thing so that's
the count sketch
but I don't know how to compute this
fast because this is a random hash
function it looks like I have to look at
every I comma J
not nice
so I want to make this faster I don't
just care about the
um
about the compression I also want the
parties to be fast
uh good
so I want every party to send not count
sketch but some sketch and I want to
design the sum sketch
I'll almost completely design it right
instead of having one hash function that
Maps
the n n by n uh Matrix Matrix entries uh
into B buckets and uh right and the
similar sine function I'll have two hash
functions and two sine functions there
will be a hash function H1 from the rows
to B and the hash function H2 from
columns to B and two sine functions that
also take the individual coordinates not
the pair and uh map them to the sign
this is basically a tensoring of two
account sketches now uh the so now I'll
just Define a structured hash function H
that Maps entry i j to
H1 of I plus H2 of J mod b
and the sine function just takes the
product fantastic
um
good and now let's now we can do count
sketch with this and that's my hash
function that's my sine function
uh and here comes the exercise
I claim that the parties can actually be
efficient that is
the parties can just compute count
sketch of count sketch one of x
and counts cage two of X I think then
they can somehow efficiently combine the
two uh row and column wise count
sketches into account sketch of the
entire Matrix
and I'll stop here so half an hour to
solve this
[Applause]
um do you have any ideas on what the
histogram of uh it counts look like in
real life ah well the question was uh
whether I I have any idea on what the
histogram of
um frequency counts look like in real
life
um
they're not worst case uh there are some
works on this so for example very often
unsurprisingly they look like power laws
they look like Supreme distributions and
things like that
um I'll mention at the beginning of the
next lecture that for these specific
distributions
for distributions that do occur in real
life uh count sketch is actually more
significantly more precise than what we
proved it's more precise log Factor uh
this is a result of a very nice paper of
Maintenance price from I think so 12 to
13. in fact there's a very recent uh
Improvement on this by Michael and
Company which I'll mention as well so
yeah
there is a work of that there's a lot
I'll say more
at the beginning next
or questions
all right let's thank uh Michael again
we have a coffee break until 11 and
we'll be back then
um in case anyone's wondering the
schedule for today is actually the same
as the schedule Workshop schedule today
there's no event at the end so
everything's at the same times they were
yesterday
um
see you all at 11.